und wir wollen einmal schauen nach
österreich jetzt in diesen minuten da
beginnt man dort mit der stufenweisen
lockerung der antigone maßnahmen und
damit wagt sich österreich als erstes
land in europa in richtung normalität
zumindest für einen schritt ab heute
dürfen alle kleinläden mit weniger als
400 quadratmetern verkaufsfläche sowie
bau- und gartenmärkte wieder öffnen
das sind immerhin 80 prozent aller
einzelhändler in einer zweiten stufe
dann ab 2 sollen alle geschäfte in
österreich wieder öffnen dürfen und ab
mitte mai dann alle lokale und
restaurants wir sprechen jetzt mit
meinem bild kollegen mattes katnik in
salzburg mathis wie ist die situation
gerade die ersten lockerungen jetzt
welche risiken gehen aber einher mit
diesen lockerungen die jetzt in diesen
minuten bei dir stattfinden
ja man ist das heißt auch noch relativ
ruhig sind noch nicht auf den straßen
unterwegs wie sich das ganze entwickeln
wird wird man in den nächsten stunden
sehen
die meisten geben hier werden
tatsächlich auch erst gegen 10 uhr
aufmachen dann geschäftige kleiner als
100 quadratmeter sind dürfen zwar heute
wieder aufsperren allerdings nur zwei
liegend nur 40 und 19 uhr
ansonsten zu den ewig nun was du noch
gefragt hast es ist so natürlich besteht
ein risiko wenn die geschäfte aufsperren
dass es jetzt wieder mehr anstecken
fälle gibt eben möchte man aber auch und
gegensätzen es ist zum beispiel so wenn
meine geschäfte betritt das auf einer
fläche von 20 quadratmetern sind nur
eine person sein dh ich habe mir das
angeschaut bei jedem leben steht stieg
das fordert außenästen dienst person
rein
das dürfen wir nur sieben personen rein
das eben einen mindestabstand im laden
darauf reduziert ist und weiter es ist
eine geschäften so dass man allen
geschäften eine maske tragen was die
österreicher dazu sagen das hat mir
gestern angehört und ich vergessen auch
unterwegs und dazu bezwingt nutzen
beitrag den wir uns das anschauen
jetzt ist positiv wichtig ist dass wir
oder wir haben jetzt sehen vor allem
einen gut lernt der abstand zu halten
masken zu tragen und die glaubt dass
kanal in dem zusammenhang ganz gut
funktionieren viele leute zurzeit von
der arbeit ich habe diese ganz wichtig
dass wieder viele beschäftigen noch
gehen geschäfte wieder aufmachen und ich
hoffe dass nicht gleich alle weder 100
sie sorgen sich stürzen
also ich wäre für eine längere zeit
gewesen habe es nicht so einig muss
nicht unbedingt gleich wieder einkaufen
gehen vielleicht ist es wichtig für die
wirtschaft das kann ich nicht beurteilen
man muss davon ausgehen dass die
bundesregierung hoffentlich weiß was sie
tut
insofern hat die krise anbieten jetzt
gesundheitliche folgen kopf sondern
wirtschaftliche und vielleicht ist es
gar nicht so schlecht weil ja die
menschen respekt haben das heißt dass
sollten nur die menschen auch außer haus
gehen
die wirklich wissen das und sagen ich
glaube dass jetzt so früh ist für die
online geschäfte also ich glaube dass es
besser wäre womöglich anfang mai die
chance haben auf macht dass alle
geschäfte auf gesperrt werden warum
warum kommt zum beispiel die ist ja wohl
keine namen nennen
die großmärkte der auto ist von
diplomaten muss bis sie die blumen da
gehört auch die paragraphen deren das
heute unter idiotie für mich
jan sieht die österreich erst in das
sehr verschieden also die einen sagen
ist das gut die anderen sagen na ja und
wie geschäften doch noch ein bisschen
länger zu werden können ist der letzte
jahr hat jetzt einen wichtigen punkt
angesprochen ist ja doch unfair dass
supermärkte eben neben den lebensmitteln
auch ganz ganz normale produkte
verkaufen wird
die kleinen läden und nicht aufmachen
irgend und das ist ja heute reichen
matthias lass uns noch kurz über die
schulen und universitäten in österreich
sprechen wann werden die wieder geöffnet
und unter welchen maßnahmen darüber wird
ja viel jetzt in deutschland diskutiert
schulen sollen aktuell wieder mit mai
geöffnet werden und hier wird es
wahrscheinlich eine maske nicht
verstehen allerdings wird man hier auch
erst noch mal abfahren und was
vielleicht auch noch mal ändern was zum
beispiel die matura also das deutsche
abitur betrifft da ist so dass die
mündliche matura ausfällt nur die
schrift mit stattfindet und was die
universitäten oder gar nicht mehr
aufsperren
das mag vielleicht ein sommer anders
sein dass man es doch noch prüfungen
stattfinden können aber dazu ist im
moment jetzt auch noch nichts näheres
bekannt und ich habe mir sagen lassen
ist das wahrscheinlich stand selbst
entscheiden werden ist dann sommer
vorgehen nach gebe ich dir mathis katnik
in salzburg ganz herzlichen dank für
deine einschätzung und wir schalten im
laufe des tages wieder zu dir schauen
wie die lockerung in österreich so
laufen dank der